you interviewed uh joe rogan recently
yeah and he said something that i
thought was really
really brilliant during the podcast
interview he said that he's gonna love
hearing that
very good sorry but he he said that he
realized at some point
that the turn in his opinion about ufos
happened when he realized how
desperately he wanted it to be true
this is
the human condition
we our pink matter works the same way as
everybody's pink matter and one of the
ways that our pink matter works is with
this thing with what's known as a
cognitive bias it's a mental shortcut
essentially your brain doesn't want to
process through facts over and over
again instead it wants to assume certain
facts are in place and just jump right
to the conclusion it saves energy it
saves megabytes
so what joe
what joe or joe rogan i feel weird
calling him joe i don't know him but
what joe identified on his own mr rogan
what mr rogan identified on his own yeah
was his own cognitive loop
and then he immediately grew suspicious
of that loop
that is a super powerful tool that is
something that most people never become
self-actualized enough to realize that
they have a cognitive loop let alone
questioning their own cognitive loop so
that was
when it came to this topic specifically
that was just something that i thought
was really powerful because
you learned to not just not trust
yourself for the record
after he drinks one whiskey all that
goes out
i think that was just in that moment in
time
like you know um
a moment of rose cause i i think he
still is uh
you know um
he's
he's definitely one of the things that
inspires me about joe is how open-minded
he is how curious he is he refuses to
let sort of the conformity and the
conventions
of any one community including the
scientific community be a kind of uh
thing that limits his curiosity of
asking what if
uh it's like the the whole it's entirely
possible i think that's a beautiful
thing it actually represents
what uh the best of science is that
childlike curiosity but so it's good to
sort of balance those two things but
then you have to wake up to it like
is is this is there a chance this is
true or do i just really want it to be
true and that like that hot girl that
talks to you overseas yeah
yeah
for a brief moment
there's there's actually a deeper
explanation for it that i'll tell you
off the mic that perhaps a lot of people
can kind of figure out anyway just to
take it one step further because i love
this stuff personally i love pink i love
pink matter stuff
and your interview with jack barski
jack's good a good friend of mine a good
dude an incredible person yeah in your
conversation with jack barsky
you guys he started talking to you about
how his recruiters were feeding back to
him his own beliefs his own opinions
about himself how smart he was how good
he was how uniquely qualified he was
that's all pink matter manipulation
feeding right back to the person what
they already think of themselves is a
way to get them to invest
and trust you faster because obviously
you value them for all the right reasons
because that's how they see themselves
so that that loop
that
the kgb was using with jack
jack did not wake up to that loop at the
time he woke up to it later
so it's it's happens to all of us we're
all in a loop
it's just whether it's about
oat milk or whether it's about aliens or
whether it's about
you know the democrats trying to take
your guns whatever it is everybody's in
a loop and we've got to wake up to to
ask ourselves just like you said is it
true or do we just really want it to be
true and until you ask yourself that
question you're just one of the masses
trapped in the loop
yeah that's the that's the really the
the nietzsche
gaze into the abyss it's a dangerous
thing it's that's the path to insanity
is to ask that question you want to be
doing it carefully but it's also the
place where you can truly discover
something fundamental about this world
that people don't understand and then
that and lay the groundwork for
progress scientific
uh cultural all that kind of stuff
you